[Music]
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today uh
spoiler alert guys the research on
millionaires the airtight research the
methodology was so pure and so good on
this research that if you disagree with
the conclusions of the research you're
what's known as
wrong okay in other words these are
facts databased facts they're not
feelings from your Carl Marx induced
college professor
okay these are actual
facts
79% of America's millionaires inherited
precisely
zero 5% of America's millionaires
inherited a very small amount like
$5,000 from Grandmother but not enough
to make them mathematically a
millionaire it was an insignificant
small amount but they did technically
get an
inheritance another five % inherited
money that was substantial like that
last caller or caller before no the last
caller uh after they were already
millionaires so did not become
millionaires because of inherited money
but enhanced their wealth after they
were already millionaires so let me help
you with that
790 five small five after 79 plus 5 plus
5 is
89% that's 9 out of
10 of the current
approximately 15 million millionaires in
North America became millionaires not
because of inherited
money do not let people tell that lie in
your presence because when they tell
that lie they are spreading hopelessness
they are stealing Hope from
people because if you know that nine out
of 10 of America's millionaires started
with
nothing and became millionaires not
because of inherited money that should
give you hope that you too can do
this then the only question is how did
they do it what are the best practices
well a lot of them followed the baby
steps these days I've been teaching this
stuff 30 years I mean 10 million people
have been through Financial Peace
University You' think a few of them
would get it and turn out to be
millionaires well a bunch of them got it
and turned out to be millionaires I also
want to mention that 96% of net worth
millionaires enjoy their work they're
not quiet quitters Dave and I had Tim
Smith who did let our research pull some
more data for me of the
96% uh so that's only 4% didn't enjoy
their work the 96% actually had a higher
net worth to the tune of 58% higher net
worth than those in that 4% who didn't
enjoy their work oh he pared the pared
the data out wow even more what tells me
that doing something something you enjoy
is the key to working harder and longer
in that sacrificial time more creatively
you're getting promoted more you're
putting your best output out which means
you're getting rewarded for the output
so we don't want to miss that side of it
the baby steps huge chunk living unless
you make the discipline piece but you
have greater discipline when you
actually enjoy showing up and you also
get better results when you enjoy it we
also found okay what are the top 10
careers fields that people picked out uh
number one engineer at the break we met
a baby step Millionaire's engineer he's
a baby step millionaire met him at the
break at the commercial break just a
minute ago sitting here in the lobby
engineer 45 years old okay um that's it
I mean number two accountant number
three
teacher yeah I don't agree with that I
don't care if you agree with it you're
wrong the number three most
occurring career field was teacher
number four business executive whatever
that means could mean anything and
number five was attorney y Doctors
medical doctors didn't even make the top
five what do all five of those people
have in common it took us a while to
figure this one out they all are
processed people they have to follow a
series of principles if you're an
engineer and you don't follow the
principles the bridge falls down
if you're an accountant you don't get to
be creative there's accounting
principles you follow those Creative
Accounting is called embezzlement you go
to jail okay you don't get to be
creative with your accting teachers
follow a system a lesson plan a series
of testing to create the desired outcome
business Executives obviously following
best practices attorneys you got one way
you can conduct yourself in front of
your honor the judge or he'll put your
butt in jail for contempt you don't get
to make up stuff in the courtroom
there's a process that the law requires
you abide to or you lose the
case these are processed people and so
when it came to money they found a
process and they submitted themselves to
that process they didn't try to go well
I don't know if I agree with that I'm 18
years old and I watched a tick tock
video well don't be stupid okay don't be
stupid it'll cause you to be broke
instead you go I'm going to figure out
what the freaking process is and I'm
going to follow it and that's what
causes people to be millionaires and
they do it over and over and over today
we've got a Property Restoration guy a
big U entrepreneur guy insurance claims
process Air Force try PL flying a plane
different than you're supposed to fly it
it's called crashing right um a digital
guy I mean Information Systems guy you
know syntax when you start writing code
you got one slash out of place the whole
thing B buggers up doesn't work it has
to have it perfect there you have to
follow process right same thing all the
way down the dad gum list right and
today is today is the examples followed
it and we didn't set these calls up we
just put it out there if you want to
call in if you won the lottery we'll put
you on here but you're not normal as
millionaires go If you inherited $10
million and your uncle owns a hotel
chain that's great uh but but you're not
normal we'll put you on here because we
want to hear your story